[Música]
bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia donde tocamos los
principales temas de la campaña
electoral francesa tomamos dirección a
bárcenas donde vamos a hablar de cultura
[Música]
[Aplausos]
llegamos a marsella y me encuentro
frente al museo de la civilización
europea y mediterránea ciudad-puerto
marsella es la segunda ciudad más grande
de francia todo un crisol de culturas y
civilizaciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y la elección de un candidato que apoya
la cultura aún más no tengo la impresión
de que haya uno que se desmarca al
respecto o asilo con cobos
ah
este es un tema importante y creo que
necesitaremos tiempo no es algo que
vamos a resolver en uno o dos años esto
tomará diez años
[Música]
francés conocida en el mundo entero por
su arte su cine y su literatura el
sector aporta millones de euros a la
economía pero qué futuro hay para la
cultura después de dos años de pandemia
el concepto de excepción cultural
promovido por francia en los 80 se
refiere a que la cultura no es un
producto como cualquier otro la
dimensión económica de la cultura no es
ignorada pero el rol que juega en el
desarrollo personal de cada uno es tan
importante que las producciones
culturales no pueden quedarse solo en
manos del mercado en ese contexto el
sector cultural que en francia
representa
670 mil empleos directos reciben
numerosas subvenciones tanto del
gobierno central como de las regiones
que tienen a la cultura como una de sus
competencias en 2022 el presupuesto del
ministerio de cultura sobrepasada por
primera vez los 4 mil millones de euros
un alza del 75 % con respecto a 2021
detrás de estas cifras inéditas el
objetivo del gobierno es salvar sectores
fuertemente impactados por la crisis
sanitaria como las artes escénicas el
patrimonio el cine o el sector
audiovisual a estas sumas hay que
agregar dispositivos estatales como
ayudas por la interrupción de la
actividad o el desempleo parcial para
los empleados de la cultura
[Música]
marsella trae año tras año nuevos
habitantes muchos de ellos artistas le
preguntamos qué importancia tiene para
ellos la cultura
[Música]
y creo que la cultura es como una
terapia me entiende entonces un
candidato que no considera en la cultura
en su programa tiene pocas
probabilidades de que los trabajadores
del sector voten por ella
la compañía
la campaña presidencial es muy
complicada para mí la elección de un
candidato que apoye a la cultura aún más
no tengo la impresión de que haya uno
que se desmarca al respecto honestamente
[Música]
y uno se enriquece uno crece con la
cultura
y no tener mucho acceso a la cultura
puede limitar puede poner frenos la
cultura permite crear redes
si no le doy esta cultura y estas
oportunidades a mis hijos hoy no sé
quién lo hará
más ella es la más precaria de las seis
mayores ciudades francesas
aquí dos veces más pobreza que en parís
en los barrios del norte cumple un
sentimiento de abandono del acceso a la
cultura no está garantizado para hablar
de esto nos reunimos en el corazón de
esos barrios del norte con sal
inmigrantes y activista social y miembro
de la asociación la sal de la vida
[Música]
salinger así como se explica ese
aislamiento cultural que hay en los
barrios del norte de marsella
este aislamiento cultural viene del
hecho de que durante décadas ha habido
una voluntad política de entrar en la
cultura clásica hacia estos territorios
porque había una imagen muy peyorativa
de los habitantes de estos barrios y eso
que se trata de territorios y lugares de
vida donde hay mucho potencial porque
hay una diversidad a la vez cultural y
étnica que permitiría dar una imagen
singular de marsella en septiembre el
presidente manuel macrón visitó esta
ciudad y prometió grandes inversiones en
cultura vivienda seguridad y en
transportes eso puede ayudar justamente
a disminuir este aislamiento si pero
bajo una condición que se siente a las
personas indicadas a la mesa muy seguido
cuando uno quiere hacer cosas preparar
un escritorio o reformarlo encuentra
todo lo que necesita en el terreno mismo
me refiero a los ciudadanos y
asociaciones hay que apoyarse en las
instancias que ya existen y sus el
dinero no puede conseguirlo todo si no
ponemos a las personas implicadas a
cargo entonces es necesario obviamente
obtener el financiamiento pero también
son necesarias que puedan implicarse no
sólo una vez sino que a mediano y largo
plazo para redinamizar estos territorios
en estos barrios del norte en un gran
tejido asociativo usted forma parte de
eso justamente es que ese trabajo puede
ayudar a reducir esta idea de que la
cultura es un tema de élite de
privilegiados
todo depende de lo que consideremos con
la cultura si se trata de la cultura de
moza de beethoven de disimulo 18 si hay
vacío es decir hay un abismo entre
nosotros y el resto de la población pero
hoy en el siglo 21 hay distintas
culturas que vienen de diferentes partes
del mundo
marsella es una ciudad mundo es
lamentable ignorar esta riqueza entonces
creo que en conjunto con estas
estructuras asociaciones y habitantes
que representen diferentes culturas
ancestrales y nuevas de países diversos
podríamos crear una cultura un poco
extraterrestre distinta
finalmente que habría que hacer para
mejorar el acceso de estos barrios a la
cultura
este es un tema importante y creo que
necesitaremos tiempo no es algo que
vamos a resolver en uno o dos años esto
tomará diez años hay una fractura
territorial una fractura en los
transportes es necesario también que los
jóvenes se apropien en la cultura en su
diversidad y lo que representa y debemos
hacer que la autocensura que se impone
en los habitantes de los barrios
populares desaparezca pero la juventud
necesita ayuda para terminar con esta
autocensura porque necesitamos que gente
que venga del exterior pueda decir a
estos habitantes a estos colectivos y
asociaciones que ellos se representan
algo innovador algo bello que sería
interesante construir se alentó a ellos
muchas gracias a librarse
detrás mío se encuentra en la ópera de
marsella un lugar considerado por mucho
como reservado a unos privilegiados para
cambiar esta idea sus miembros toman una
vez por semana sus instrumentos para
enseñar la música clásica a los niños de
los barrios más precarios de marsella el
reportaje de karina ya bus
bienvenidos a mal pase un barrio en el
norte de marsella desde hace un mes dos
veces por semana aquí se trabaja el
ritmo
es el primer paso antes de pasar a los
instrumentos
es bello y también es nuevo miren cómo
brilla cada niño parece tener la
decisión tomando el violín y la viola o
el doble bajo
como ha sido con todos los yolo
yo lo sé
hola
es grandioso ver como la música puede
ayudar a todos estos niños que nunca han
estado en contacto con la música clásica
encontrar su espacio en la vida en el
mundo y en una orquesta sinfónica
en la orquesta de todas las clases son
gratuitas la única obligación es
comprometerse por tres años su hermano
estaba muy contento de formar parte del
proyecto ahora él quiere intentar con
otros instrumentos así que tengo que ver
si puedo encontrar clases sin embargo no
siempre es fácil encontrar donde
practicar en el distrito debido a la
falta de instituciones dedicadas a la
música
alexis sigue el programa de
conservatorio eligió el contrabajo
además empezó clases de piano y guitarra
su sueño volver a sentir la adrenalina
del escenario
como en este concierto que dieron en
junio del año pasado en este gran teatro
en el centro de la ciudad
[Música]
la predicción es de kilómetro
y
como
tenemos
como alexis su hermano menor julián
también quiere seguir el camino de la
música
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de elecciones
2022 un tour por francia dejamos la
costa mediterránea en dirección del
centro de francia gracias por su
preferencia
[Música]